do you ever worry you're on the wrong
side of history because you just you're
consistently siding with and defending
bullies yeah I'll tell you what happens
you know people like you Skylar only
ever watch the videos that are
supporting the speech of people you
don't like and you ignore it when I make
videos defending the speech of people on
your side is that sensational for you
I'm not super familiar with your videos
doesn't show up in my suggested feed
alright welcome to this week's
installment of devil's advocate I'm your
host scarlet turn today on the show we
have a man you can follow him on YouTube
it's Tim cast he's been talking a lot
about big tech that's been a topic of
the day censorship as it's called from
those on the right so yeah we'll get
into all of it and do kind of a deep
dive mr. Tim Poole thanks for coming on
thanks for having me Skylar well I'm
glad to have you on first off I want to
make sure I don't misrepresent you but
where do you consider yourself as far as
lining up politically moderate
center-left ish okay no yes so Center
leftist moderate like would you like
Dave Rubin or you know like to left of
Rubin yeah so not as far as Bernie
Sanders but I definitely liked Bernie
you know in 2016 okay well that might
come as a surprise to a lot of people
obviously because you've sort of been
the biggest champion of I don't know if
people call it sort of new regulations
or a new way of looking at big tech and
what you claim is sort of a monopoly on
speech particularly Facebook YouTube
Iran Joe Rogan's program recently so let
me ask you so I guess let's let's start
with this YouTube right um first let me
ask you let me let you speak in your own
words why do you have a problem with the
current practices of social media well
if one side is being removed from the
conversation by a massive multi-billion
dollar national corporation with no
accountability then our society is going
to be dictated by small well it's very
simple
Mark Zuckerberg is not the President of
the United States nor is sundar Pichai
they are certainly exercising
international ideas over Americans so if
you know these big tech companies can't
be held to account if they dominate the
market if they restrict legal speech
you're gonna end up with a repressive
technocratic fascistic government I
don't think anybody wants that right so
you know we want to address it before it
gets too bad and it's already pretty bad
Wow there was a lot of objectives there
color me impressed let me ask you this
I would imagine that that stems from
obviously being more of more classical
liberal this idea of you being anti
censorship would be probe freedom Pro
Liberty to an extent oh yeah so let me
ask you this why should YouTube a
private company be forced to carry
someone on their platform for example
recently there was a we'll get into that
Vox with Carlos Mazon Stefan Crowder
why should YouTube be forced to act as a
mouthpiece but why all the sudden when
it comes to private companies like
YouTube are you looking for big
government regulation it depends on
scale and you know a lot of these issues
with free speech have there's a nuance
here right it's not necessarily that
every single platform every everywhere
every single time should be forced to
carry speech but YouTube's definitely
dominated online video in terms of
user-generated content there's no other
game in town Shore Vimeo kind of exists
but through various business practices
you know YouTube has come out on top so
if you really want to reach people and
have your voice be heard or you know
allow people to actually subscribe and
follow your content whether or not
YouTube promotes it YouTube is where you
have to be so because they've started to
dominate a massive portion of the market
they're starting to have negative
effects on our public discourse whereas
the commons this idea of this public
space where you could gather used to be
in the real world it's not just YouTube
it's its Twitter its Facebook these
platforms are having a serious impact
and we know they are because we
constantly hear about Russia interfering
in our elections so if that's true then
we need protections for US citizens to
allow them to speak otherwise their
rights will be stripped away by
billionaires who don't know or care
about them um what kind of regulation
what kind of protections I guess that's
that is a big challenge right it's with
YouTube it's particularly challenging
because whether or not YouTube
promotes your content is very different
from whether or not they host your
content and allow people to find it so
on the right side of YouTube you have
that recommendation bar that to me seems
more like a privilege not a right
but there are a lot of people who have
broken no rules who find their channels
put in what's called a limited state
meaning that people can't even search
for it anymore which effectively removes
it so that's a suppression of someone's
spending you see that as a problem you
see that as a problem with the companies
like YouTube doing that not putting
someone really not promoting not
amplifying alright like hate speech you
see that I want to make sure that's a
that's a human right that's the First
Amendment right to Tim Poole no no not
at all and neither is monetization right
so it's an this this gets into the heart
of regulation as well in the sense that
YouTube acts as an advertising agency as
a marketing agency and a hosting service
all rolled up into one and if you run
afoul of any one of these different
aspects of the company you lose access
to everything which is where you know
there's a potential argument for
breaking up YouTube into its into
various forms or guaranteeing the right
to certain like limitations on what
YouTube can or can't do so if if they're
going to suppress legal speech in this
country based on some international
standard that doesn't apply to Americans
but there's nowhere else for Americans
to go and they are dominating the
conversation then some kind of
restriction has to guarantee speech well
some of those so obviously right is sort
of self-serving recently you did a video
I want to make sure I'm just on
Pinterest and I caught removed I know
you got really upset about that can you
explain that to people who don't know
you did a video on Pinterest you know
sort of making some accusations and I
think you dog is somebody and it was
removed and you were your mouth yeah and
this is probably the perfect example of
why any kind of restrictions on speech
particularly when they say it's hate
speech is so insidious I did a video
commenting on publicly available
information but because the story was
damaging to this massive billion-dollar
corporation apparently it's my
understanding right so this is where
right so far in the story haven't
reported this yet but it seems like a
legal firm filed a you know privacy
complaint and YouTube just takes the
comment
down even though it's public so this is
you know a massive legal firm with
probably hundreds of millions of dollars
maybe tens of mine I don't know getting
journalism taken down by a by lying
essentially or putting pressure on
YouTube and to be clear for those who
don't know this information was made
public by James O'Keefe so you know they
can check sources for themselves right
so so so James O'Keefe doesn't expose
any any no it's call it thought yeah
well yeah yeah you have to like the guy
but he had a whistleblower around the
record and if and if you want if y'all
want to trust James you can trust the
guy who did get fired from from
Pinterest saying this happened okay now
if you want to if you want to argue that
journalism violates someone's privacy I
think you're wrong but James O'Keefe did
publish someone's name
I still think James O'Keefe is in the
right on the issue but then it gets even
crazier when I'm simply commenting on
what everyone already knows and they
still say you cannot do that now you
have massive on unaccountable companies
like no one elected Pinterest to
determine who what beliefs you're
allowed to have but they are suppressing
information and once people found out
because regulation is coming Pinterest
then acts in the interest or I should
say YouTube these other platforms cuz
even Twitter took down James o keeffe's
videos they're protecting each other as
far as I'm concerned because they know
regulations and their bottom dollar
that's the key there's as far as I want
to make sure if people understand as far
as Tim Poole is concerned let me ask you
this many say that you're more moderate
left but you just mentioned you know
James O'Keefe and Pinterest and
obviously defended Stefan Trotter as the
Carlos Messiah conflict
do you ever worry on the wrong side of
history because you just you're
consistently siding with and defending
bullies is that over Korea but I've made
several videos in the past several weeks
defending the left I made a video
yesterday defending an anti own anti
fascist who had who has suspended from
Twitter because his book had you know
KKK head signs you know so it's it's
I'll tell you what happens you know
people like you Skyler only ever watch
the videos that are supporting the
speech of people you don't like and you
ignore it when I make videos defending
the speech of people on your side is
that sensational work for you well I'm
not super familiar with your videos
doesn't show up in my suggested feed
that's probably true too yeah
so I don't listen I'm not as I haven't
seen all of your videos but if you say
that you know I'll take your word for it
and I'll tell you what's really funny is
this this author who got suspended from
Twitter which he shouldn't have because
of his book cover starts ragging on me
when he's complaining about it I
defended the guy you know so I'll tell
you what men I'm gonna defend speech I
defended flag-burning right my
principles are where they lie it doesn't
matter I I don't you know in fact I find
myself more likely to agree with the
speech of people who are moderate left I
think there's a lot of people way too
far to the left then I would a
conservative but the issue is it's it's
obvious well then what they come for you
then they come for me well then why
would you defend someone like like a
Stefan Crowder right with a smaller guy
like Carlos mazaa and and you know
you're less than a hundred thousand
followers that's a clear example of
Crowder obviously had violated Terms of
Service by making hateful content which
YouTube said and a big channel it's
almost four million subscribers going
after a lifelong LGBTQ advocate that I
was that not a prime example of first
YouTube said Stephen didn't break any
rules
so did he monetize them so you know they
did because he caused in their in their
view they said it was harmful to the
community but here's the bigger problem
would you prefer it if Carlos masa was
banned from Twitter and YouTube is that
is that what you're advocating for
because Carlos Maz has repeatedly done
the exact same thing in fact one of the
big problems is first of all I
understand comedy right I'm a big fan of
George Carlin and George Carlin has a
set has he had this bit in the early 90s
where he used every racial slur in the
book and said it's not the words it's
the person behind the words you've got
to be worried about and that and the
reason why that's so important is that
Carlos Mazda used those words on himself
if we held everyone to the same standard
Carlos Mazda would have been banned from
YouTube way before steven crowder ever
got to the point of criticizing him well
no no that's that's a false equivalency
if we're gonna use George Carlin's
example it would be yes the person
behind them it's just like it's not the
same for a black person to
reappropriation calling them that carlos
maza can use those words someone like a
stephane credits he was using it clearly
in a derogatory way it's the person who
is not an ally so you agree with George
Carlin's position on it that it's it's
the person behind it and the intent the
context that matters context is what's
important right
yeah it's context and of course the
context is problematic when you see that
you know someone like Stefan Crowder
clearly violated guidelines and it was
the harassing content well if you agree
the context is relevant then we're
talking about a comedian who's
describing a person the way they
described themselves you know and what's
really important here is because this is
a common tactic we see from you know
activists like Carlos Massa
interestingly who repeatedly is called
for various people to be taken down
you know the Karl's maza is this is a
screenshot so I haven't confirmed this
but apparently referred to gay men as
ghouls like in an absolutely derogatory
way so if we're gonna if we're gonna
take him at his word and that's how he
describes people then I don't trust him
when he describes himself that it's
supposed to be you know ingest or
reappropriation a language it shouldn't
matter if you know what took took back
to the point I kind of derailed these
activists you know what they've done
with Crowder is they've gone through two
years worth of content and snipped
together all of these out of context
times he said certain things but YouTube
realized when you watch the full segment
it was a passing moment and it wasn't
targeting Carlos specifically based on
those traits it was just him talking
about something and then mentioning the
identity of maza
by all means you can be mad at Crowder
for doing that I willing to listen to
your opinion
but we go back and look at what Carlos
maza saying throw milkshakes at people
and he actually and again I want to
clarify didn't confirm this tweet yet
what's going around now because masa has
repeatedly referred to minorities
there's a lot of that in your content if
I'm a say a lot of unconfirmed
screenshots and tweets but you know
listen that's actually not true at all
no I maybe less than I would say agree
to disagree but only if I there was even
a slight chance no is incorrect which we
know is not the case here you are yeah
because I use I actually use news guard
which is a third-party rating agency
actually have great disagreements with
but it was it on purpose as a check on
my own personal bias so yes everything I
used is confirmed as familiar with news
guard I tend to reference vice and Vox
quite a bit let me ask I
was the founding member of vice news so
you'll probably trust me and that regret
no well good for you where you know
you're not working for them anymore I
guess right no what can I visit let's
circle back to that maybe we can do it a
shallow dive because that seems about
where we're going here let me ask you
this though do you understand that
freedom of speech right it's it we're
talking about people who've taken
advantage of the systems that be in the
inherent balances therein right people
who've been in positions of power and
oppression and people who have been in
historically positions of power and
oppression people like yourself people
like Stefan Trotter people like those
kneel right people like those you know
who we see it what is it what do you
mean by people like me well people like
just people white males in the United
States are you are you are you making a
derogatory comment on my mixed-race
heritage is that is that you mean my
people like you oh yeah that's right I'm
sorry this is a part where you pulled a
trump card that you have that's
somewhere new 23andme there's enough
Korean for me to give you a pass and
considering mom well listen let's be
honest that the Koreans haven't been the
same kind of oppressed class in the
United States well we agree as LGBTQ as
trans people in the United States today
or black people given slavery have
koreans been slaves in the United States
have they been burned at the stake for
being witches well I will give you I do
recognize that certain communities face
you know different and sometimes worse
prejudices for sure how do we weigh that
is the bigger challenge I mean my family
dealt with you know with World War two
and the racism towards the Japanese that
affected every Southeast Asian person
including my family because most people
couldn't tell the difference so now
you're saying all Asians were the same
so I'm saying racist Americans couldn't
tell the difference and would take out
on my family 100% yes not all Americans
are racist I think it was you know
throughout our history we've had serious
problems with racism but I'll tell you
what America has probably done the best
job of getting rid of it and protecting
marginalized groups you know and I
reflect on this fairly often because I
recognize miscegenation was only made
nationally legal in like 1967 there are
still countries where I personally can't
go because of my family and it's
dangerous so America I feel safe and
free
that's why I really do appreciate what
this country does well I think what
people people look at you they wouldn't
they wouldn't racist Americans as we put
a woman that's rich can somebody who
lines up with the alt-right and regular
basis but then let's let's get let's
assume that's correct
um listen do you not see that inherently
people who've benefited from the systems
of imbalance powers-that-be them using
their speech in a way that is harassing
that is intimidate you know in ways that
that make marginalized people feel
unsafe
that makes speech less free when you
look at the entire was it what does it
mean less free it means an crippled and
marginalized classes are afraid to speak
out because people and systems of power
people in positions of power are
speaking against them and that's why
there does need to be a balance when it
comes to what speech is permissible
everybody feels that way about
everything there are white working-class
people who are scared to speak up for
what they see is you know they're there
as oppression there are white men who
feel the same way now certainly I
understand systemic racism and I've done
documentaries about it but you can't
target a poor individual because of the
color of their skin no matter what the
color of their skin is so you know if
you want to look at a racial group as a
monolith well I think that's
particularly racist
especially when you yourself just
accused me of being a white male not
realizing I've had white supremacists
attack me and my family and that's
something I get a lot from people on the
left now why would they attack you and
your family supremacists my family is is
mixed race real so they vandalized my
family's home if they're bricks through
the window because they don't like the
fact that an Asian woman was was was
race-mixing with a white man they didn't
and then I grow up having that as a part
of my family history being told by my
grandparents how they had to flee from
state-to-state because of these laws and
what do I get finally when I'm older you
know you know I look at I thought to
myself when I'm older and America does
away with this racism week we
continually do a better job I will truly
be free instead what I end up finding is
a regressive left-wing activist group
that refuses to judge me based on the
content of my character and repeatedly
points the finger at me and calls me a
white male ignoring the fact that I have
been oppressed and these these white
wealthy liberal progressives haven't
they don't care though
listen I'm not ignoring the fact that
you've you've been oppressed I'm simply
saying that a funded ironic that you
would encourage the systems that be to
continue unfettered to oppress others it
would seem that you would want to help
those who would be in the same situation
that your family found yourself in but
let me ask you safer much minority left
us would the UK would Canada Sweden I
mean all these places have some
limitations on speech outside of the
United States they have speech laws have
hate speech laws and it doesn't seem as
though it's a problem there it doesn't
infringe on people's rights would you do
we not think that there's an appropriate
level of regulation as it pertains to
speech as we see everywhere else in the
world well there's certainly been
problems but let me let me ask you a
question would you be upset if you made
a joke and got arrested
let's look let's say you made a joke
about the alt-right and you said you
know oh these all right guys
somebody should throw a brick or
milkshake out would you be upset if they
came and arrested you for saying that
well no because those are white males
and positions of power so that's
different I'm speaking truth to power
not speaking from a position of power to
oppress you specifically you would be ok
if you're white so you'd be fine if they
came and arrested you because you're a
white male well I'm saying there was no
scenario under which that would happen
because of the gun you're actually
you're actually right it's kind of funny
like when we see count Deng killa make a
joke with his dog and he goes he gets
arrested for it and then you have this
other British woman comedian it tell
people they're milkshakes are pathetic
and they should throw battery acid
instead and and in that regard she gets
defended by the press so you're right
there's a double standard go hold on I
think you're not being honest the guy
the guy thought right a dog to do a Nazi
salute right a very hateful gesture that
comes loaded with all kinds of
historical and contextual baggage to use
your your argument from George Carlin
before I think you need to be honest
yeah I think that there are lines and
teaching a dog to do a gesture that
could cause serious harm to other
individuals like what hot well people
who are survivors from that air in time
from World War two like you talked about
with your parents I don't think they'd
be very happy actually no might might my
parents appreciate the humor they do and
their numerous examples of them you know
I'm a product of my parents and I'll
tell you exactly why free speech was so
important to them
when my grandparents wanted to be free
to love who they loved they had to fight
against an oppressive culture that
didn't want them to speak up about why
they should be allowed to live together
and marry and have children if we if we
continued on a path of some arbitrary
you know force determining what is or
isn't offensive then you will never see
the advancement of civil rights again
because society as a whole the moral
majority will always stop people from
speaking out over what's right so I
learned that firsthand and what I see
today is I don't see modern
conservatives like you know Crowder
attacking me based on my race they're
judging me based on the content of my
character someone I can choose to be as
opposed to something I can't change but
it's the it's it's the it's these
countries like Sweden in the UK that are
choosing not to ask me what to do better
but saying you look a certain way
therefore we're going to judge you and
that is contrary to the dream of Martin
Luther King jr. at least in my you know
my understanding of what he said so I
don't understand how what you're saying
aligns with the dream of dr. King I
don't you know it's a bit okay summer
wordplay all right this we see this
happen a lot right with Dave Rubin I'm a
classical liberal none you invoke
something and ignore you know Strom
Thurmond southern Strom Thurmond
Southern Strategy Strom Thurmond
Southern Strategy google it right okay
but let me go back to this here what
does it benefit people tavaa don't do an
Aussie split right there is a scale you
have to weigh was it benefit people for
someone to make a racist joke or harass
a fine young journalist like mr. Mizzou
at Vox what is that benefit you know
that there was a story where a man it
was in the in World War 2 era talk I
think was in Finland taught his dog to
do the Nazi salute and the Nazis were
furious because it made them it made the
Nazis look silly it belittled them it
took their power away
she ridicule is one of the most powerful
ways to take someone's power away by
mocking them and making people laugh and
humiliate that's why you know Karl's
Mazdas had thrown milkshake he wants
people to be him humiliated because he
wants to strip them out of any kind of
professions like you have a problem with
that sounds it looked at people yeah it
sounds to me like you're saying it's
okay for a dog to do a Nazi salute
because it's humiliating Nazis but it's
not okay to throw a milkshake at someone
because
it's a milkshake can actually cause
physical harm
you could you could in some
circumstances actually kill somebody did
you have one of those unconfirmed
sources for happy meal deaths each year
with with Frosty's have it well you know
who are allergic to dairy but I do think
that's kind of silly right you know
admittedly milkshakes are probably the
lowest tier of violence you probably get
to outside of like splashing someone
with water but the issue is if you if
you have the intent to cause harm to
somebody you damage their property
you've you've crossed that net boundary
and admittedly you know there there's no
simple line as to whether or not
something I should say there there is
something we can clearly use to
delineate whether or not you've crossed
the line legally and we have those
standards at least in the US Supreme
Court rulings but but things really do
get challenging when you have a comedian
the UK say your milkshakes are pathetic
why don't you throw battery acid because
you know then you could look to what
this woman said about throwing battery
acid at somebody and this is a white
woman who said it she's using her
position of power oh I thought you
didn't like identity politics well there
it is but continue I'll just you know I
just said listen Brodus couldn't let
that one go and check but yeah so so I'm
actually isn't that to speak to your
understanding of the context of you
thank you you're right if you think that
white people in massive positions of
power on national radio saying things
could be could be damaging then you
would certainly agree this woman talking
about battery acid would be should be
criminal in the same capacity is a guy
making his dog do it do a Nazi salute
whole thing is I think it depends in the
target and I think a big part of is
contextually when we're talking about
protecting minority classes the most
vulnerable among us who need protection
versus people who are the ones doing the
oppressing people like antiphon people
like the Trump alt rightists people
right so therein lies the problem you
wouldn't you would judge someone not
based on their actions but their their
skin color no are there are their ideas
but I do think that listen that goes to
the territory in Western society that
there is a historical context to being
particularly a white male that requires
a more prudent approach so so now here
comes the the big problem that I have
what you know speaks to my politics
there was a time in this in the United
States where absolutely we have
oppression and we still do to a certain
extent right racism sexism these things
are still problems to various degrees
but admittedly I think people can
recognize we've done a really really
good job in the past when we had Jim
Crow when we had segregation these
things you had people who had racist
views who had supremacist views and over
time through free speech through free
expression through our Constitution
we've actually done away with these
things and we have now in more free and
equal society the problem is you the
argument you're presenting kind of flips
that back on its head where you make the
presumption that because someone is a
mixed-race or black or Latino they're
weaker than you so what happens when you
have someone who is mixed who finally
become successful I then get to hear how
I'm weaker and less than that's not
something I want to hear and if you keep
telling people they're victims
you're putting them in this in this
mindset you're telling them you can
never change your life and that's not
true it's absolutely not sure I could
flip that in the same way and if you
don't acknowledge the victimization that
has occurred at the hands of the
oppressors through the systems that be
you are not helping them if you simply
tell someone who's a minority that all
if you work hard enough employer stuff
up by your bootstraps you'll be ok
that's not reality so I'm simply
speaking the truth to them let me I want
to get back to big tech but let me ask
you a couple other questions here
Kyle cash who've I just had the Harvard
application rescinded and that's been
ousted trending everywhere what's what
seems to have you spoken on that I have
actually and so look you'll find I am
fairly middle the wrote a lot of these
issues Harvard in the past its it was
written about in 2017 I believe by an
Atlantic journalist before the Kyle cash
F thing ever became newsworthy they have
rescinded offers to many people based on
past speech and offensive things they've
said so there's there's a complicated
issue there in that it's not about Kyle
it's about is our society willing to
guide and forgive go tell you what
happens if you take someone like Kyle
who has apologized and says he will do
better and he's sorry and is even
willing to sit down with the diversity
and inclusivity board at Harvard to do
better but you reject him well then what
can he do
apologizing didn't work well because
maybe he will not use the n-word like 16
times and so
he wanted traitors in private texts he
agreed with you he completely agree with
you so you would reject people who would
agree with you because at one point when
they were young they did they didn't you
know they did something wrong well so I
mean that's what listen let's be honest
about what he said so what you're just a
fan of using the n-word repeatedly is
that what I'm hearing was that about
right here's the fan no I think do it I
think it was absolutely wrong to do it
but I'll tell you what you take somebody
who did wrong and tell them we will
never forgive you we will ban you from
our platforms and you know what they'll
do they'll turn around and look for
anybody who will accept them people you
know people don't want to be alone they
get scared but I'll tell you what I'm
willing to forgive there's a BuzzFeed
writer who made a very offensive
statement and I tweeted in support of
him when he apologized because I will
always accept an apology you know look
fool me once shame on shame on you fool
me twice shame on me but there's a
youtuber named Joey Salas who did a
bunch of really offensive racist content
and at first I I smacked talked him hard
I was like I can't believe you do that
your fake news you're racist but then I
realized something there's a community
of people who are actually racist who
would love to take a big youtuber or a
famous parkland activist and rope them
to their side don't give them that
chance accept the apology ask them to do
better and if they don't later on well
you know three strikes and you're out
but if someone like Kyle says it was a
mistake and I was a kid I will say I
accept your apology because we should
always be willing to accept forgiveness
and then we can use that opportunity to
make a teaching moment and guide people
towards being you know being nicer and
more productive but Kyle is already that
person as far as I'm concerned that's it
was two years ago right it wasn't that
long ago he's oh he's only I think
eighteen years old now but if in the
past two years he's become a better
person he's realized his mistakes then
we should absolutely accept any you know
his apology and give him a chance to
show others how to be better otherwise
you will create the bad you create the
negative consomme sorry forgive me it
sounds to me like you're advocating
forgiveness I'm talking about your
personal I talk about the people who
would refuse to be kind and loving and
empathetic kinda create pockets look
kind of like your attitude toward
Pinterest and Vox sounds like in what
well those are big corporations but what
did you mean by that well I'm not
hearing you'd be very compassionate or
forgiving of them
like you know they've doubled down
they've refused to accept responsibility
for their their their actions they
refuse to accept that they hold massive
disproportionate power over individuals
you know Vox is back to the tune of 200
plus million by NBC as well as many
others they have massive institutional
power they have way more subscribers
than steven crowder did admittedly I
think when you look at you know Vox the
Fox Crowder thing it is a battle of the
Titans
I wouldn't call Crowder an impoverished
poor oppressed minority by no means he's
very powerful
but it's definitely not an issue of you
know Crowder oppressing this poor Karl
smiles across Mizzou wielded the force
of NBC News a massive you know how old
is NBC NB C's massive corporation with
international power he's wielding that
and all of his other media outlets that
rallied to his side to to come down on
somebody else while at the same time not
abiding by his own principles using
offensive slurs referring to to various
groups and disparaging ways and and even
encouraging people to be violent so if
Fox came out and said we recognize these
things Carlos did was was wrong and we
accept it
I would I would accept their apology
100% like I did for BuzzFeed that
BuzzFeed writer posted an offensive
tweet he apologized for it and people
didn't want me to accept his apology but
I will always give someone a chance to
do better the same is true for Sarah
John but her apology was was I mean she
immediately doubled down after the fact
right Sarah John's the one from the New
York Times who for years was posting
racist content finally apologizes saying
you know I was using the language of my
oppressor but then goes right back to
using similar language and attacking
people so listen I will accept your
apology but if it's insincere and you
double down that you're not gonna get
any any special favors from me well I'll
be sure to let everyone know from a
minority oppressed class if they need to
apologise to Tim Poole before we can
allow them a place in the public square
to go back to big tech here you just
mentioned NBC New York Times so let me
ask you this was a comparison should it
would you support NBC or New York Times
being forced through regulation to allow
any voice on their platform like a
Stefon Crowder or whoever Oh Gavin
McInnes or yourself do you believe that
they should be required to allow
everyone who wants to you for example
position
right now we're getting to the publish
force platform argument if NBC is acting
in the capacity of a publisher they
actually do have some restrictions and
regulations on when to allow people to
appear and whatnot particularly in
dealing with elections that I can
understand but if NBC has an editorial
choice and a finite amount of space I
totally get it
Twitter tells everybody it's a service
for you to share your ideas but now they
act specifically as an editorial service
and look you want to argue about Twitter
being a platform or a publisher Facebook
has to gone both ways arguing in court
they're both a publisher and then later
on their platform because they want the
protections well and they also want the
benefits of both sides but Pinterest
goes one step beyond in that they
absolutely have an editorial guideline
on what is or isn't acceptable they've
determined that a pro-life website is
fake news okay that's an editorial
position right you're paid rest let's
have a legal authority over what is true
or not
no but they just like you just like
YouTube they do have guidelines that one
signs on to when using that platform
which preserves them the right to get
their one of anybody that's accept
YouTube but doesn't actually get rid of
people they deemed to be fake news they
actually have some kind of like
algorithmic you know issues and that's
where we go back to the promotion not
being a right but a privilege but what
they'll do is they'll put a Wikipedia
link underneath it they'll let your
speech stay up I do think it becomes
problematic when they put people's
videos into what they call a limited
state because that's actually
suppressing someone's speech if you're
if you're dominating the market if you
have a met a disproportionate amount of
control it vertically or otherwise over
you know public policy of public
discourse well then there's got to be
some protections at that speech but to
the point of Pinterest Pinterest behind
the scenes we learned absolutely has an
editorial position in which case they
are not a platform and their ally up
there they're liable for the libel on
their platform so I think what we need
to see is maybe we'll see it maybe we
won't
someone needs to actually just sue
Pinterest for what one of their users
did and argue in court they've given up
their two-thirty protections when they
decided to implement an editorial policy
although it's going to be my last
question because I do have to get going
here in a perfect world how would the
great Tim Poole deal with us what would
you like to see happen with these big
companies I'm still not seeing the
consistency for example in the
application toward let's say a bakery or
like the New York Times these publishers
in big tech it seems inconsistent so
clarify for me and people who are
listener how would you deal in a perfect
actually I actually do fall into the the
camp where I believe the bakery thing is
complicated talking about the the bakery
I believe in Colorado with the gay
wedding that's a complicated issue
because you have a single Baker who has
asked to produce a custom message on a
cake he didn't want to do but he did you
know he did say he would service the
couple just not with a custom cake and
that falls into a similar First
Amendment argument that twitter has
Twitter says we have a First Amendment
right to not publish speech we don't
agree with I actually do agree with that
up until you look at the scale of the
two businesses a single baker making a
cake is not going to impact national or
international politics Twitter is so
Twitter's grown to a point now where the
president is on the platform right if
Donald Trump was hiding in the back of
the bakery and the only way you could
ever hear we had to say was getting in
the bakery I think we'd have a problem
there
the president's on Twitter the president
is a nominee other platforms talking
about his plans and his policies and so
we've actually had court decisions that
he is creating public forums well if
that's true and we shouldn't allow a
massive multinational private entity the
right to bar American citizens from the
speech of the president but more
importantly twitter has investors from
Saudi Arabia and foreign countries do we
want Twitter which has interests from
foreign you know governments the ability
to censor American speech I think the
answer is no look if a baker doesn't
want to make you a cake I actually think
you probably should but you can
absolutely call up another number and
find another Baker within a mile or two
do I think it's right it's a complicated
question oh there's only one Twitter
right there are alternatives there are
smaller platforms but the president
isn't on those platforms so where do I
go to engage in my civic and civic
discourse and trying to influence
politicians well it's going to be
Twitter but if if Jack Dorsey if a giant
got a and these other executives at
Twitter including foreign investors have
a different opinion outside of the legal
confines of the US we've got a serious
problem in that they will absolutely
allow Russians to use the platform so
long as they fall within their rules and
manipulate our our policy in our public
discourse but
American citizens who want to challenge
those opinions are being restricted yeah
that can't fly I noticed when it comes
to someone doing the Nazi salute or Kyle
Kossuth using the n-word or Stephon
Crowder harassing carlsmith azza
minority all of a sudden these issues
are more complicated but then when it
comes to a clear example of oppression
you you seem to be a little more
simplistically minded so what's let me
return this just to the final question
because listen I don't have the entire
day that's Tim cast on YouTube or
ironically they haven't removed you so
they must not be as authoritarian as you
talk about what in a perfect world Tim
fools world what would you do if you
can't summarize this right in a
paragraph for people not a soliloquy
this time
if you can't summarize this in a couple
of phrases for people who are watching
what would you do with big talk I
honestly don't know I'm not I'm not the
smartest person in the world but I can't
offer some ideas protecting the right to
legal speech that means if you say
something on the platform that falls
within the confines of the law it should
be it should remain up under certain
caveats right it is a big challenge a
lot of people will say if it's legal
speech it's protected I agree
however I have no problem with Twitter
Facebook YouTube etcetera taking someone
down who directly incites violence who
directly sends a threat those things are
violations of the law and can be removed
without a court order in my opinion for
the most part though if we're going to
have the comments if we're going to
allow people to partake in democracy
then they need access to massive tech
platforms without them being publishers
otherwise Brandon publishers break them
up something needs to be done and we
need to sit down and go over you know
what the future is gonna look like with
with politicians as well as the tech
industry but the tech industry is
flaunting the rules as far as I'm
concerned and something needs to be done
about it alright okay well listen I
don't agree I appreciate you taking the
time that's youtube.com slash Tim cast
Tim Poole thank you for being here let
us know what you think in the comment
section as to whether you are convinced
so thank you mr. Poole thanks for having
me all right are we good you can just
slam dunk him
with Skylar Turton if you enjoyed this
devil's advocate with me your host
Skylar turn click one of these videos
playing in a box there are more
installments including with John Stossel
Jordan Peterson and you can subscribe or
hit the notification bell to help with
via suggested feed and YouTube and the
algorithms with some people over there
who are doing the Lord's work at big
tech